was there any particular match that you  still wanted to bring up there's some  there's some drama people because  obviously uh  i i guess because of magnus playing  people are very interested in the norway  match and in the norway match there is a  lot of drama because we we showed the  diary game yeah aryan has resigned by  this point and apparently  uh young ludwig lost on time on uh move  38  ah yes but it was also very unclear very  unclear  you remember he mentioned that he he  played his last movie two seconds and he  he overdid it yeah yeah he over here  yeah that's at least what what we  suspect king ifan uh yeah rook of faith  was not the best move in the position  but it's playable it's nothing wrong  with it  uh but then he yeah  we think he may have uh  uh lost on time here so despite magnus  probably winning his game again  uh they're fighting for a draw in the  match they probably will make a drawing  because yeah arya lost the game yeah  aaron lost